hi I'm Nicolas booth recent TV and today
we're talking with Matt kibbe he's the
president of Freedom Works and the
author of the new book hostile takeover
resisting centralized government
stranglehold on America Matt thanks for
talking too thanks for having me Nick
you are following up on a previous book
tell us why we should be reading hostile
takeover well if you want to understand
what's going on in America this clash
from all of this freedom and bottom-up
and ability of consumers to choose
online and connect with people versus a
more and more aggressive federal
government that wants to dictate to us
how we live our lives from the top down
this clash is the most interesting thing
going on in politics in America today
now you're trying to effect a hostile
takeover of government right even as the
government is trying to do a hostile
takeover of our everyday lives who's
going to win or why are you going to win
well a takeover is when shareholders try
to kick out senior management a hostile
takeover is when senior management
fights back so this is this clash
between voters and citizens who don't
like what the government's doing to them
and senior management's including our
CEO and chief who says screw you I'm
smarter than you I'm in charge I know
what I'm doing that's what that's what a
takeover is all about and it's got to be
done from the bottom up I think all of
these forces of decentralization are
empowering voters to do things I haven't
been able to do before talk a little bit
about that like what are some of the
specific things and and you know in the
you know obviously we're in election
season part of the problem here is that
Barack Obama is very much a throwback to
a kind of best than the brightest
technocratic trust me I'm in charge
mentality but then on the Republican
side under George Bush and I mean you
wrote about this a lot you had a
Republican Party that was as awful so
what what is you know what are the
things that both in your book and
FreedomWorks more generally as a group
what are you doing to really kind of
effect change in and deep keeping things
decentralized well the phrase hostile
takeover actually comes from an op-ed
dick armey and I wrote leading up to the
2010 election where we argued we had to
beat the Republicans before we could
beat the demo
and I think that's part of the Tea Party
ethos we understand that Republicans
help get us into this fix and that's why
we play a lot in the primaries that
matters is the Tea Party of vital force
in this election I mean clearly they
energize things in 2010 and they talk to
Republicans a lesson but then when you
look at somebody like Mitt Romney when
you look at you know John Boehner Mitch
McConnell have they really gotten the
message that they need to be in favor of
much smaller government more
decentralized government more individual
and you know it's a little bit like
Groundhog Day I feel like we keep
teaching Republicans the same lesson
over and over again but the opportunity
is always at the margin in politics so
in this fight in texas between Ted Cruz
and david dewhurst you have a real
choice between a limited government
constitutional conservative and sort of
an establishment guy that that's gone
along it what are some of the other
primaries or races that you think are
particularly open to change and to
limited government tea party style
candidates well obviously the the
marquee race was the takedown of Dick
Lugar replacing with richard murdoch and
that's it demonstrates the rule here the
old rules of money name ID all of the
establishment of Dorset's coming from
Washington DC didn't save Dick Lugar
from an insurgent bottom-up campaign but
you got to look at Florida you gotta
look at Ohio Wisconsin's going to get
interesting even Pennsylvania I think
might be competitive so do you what are
your hopes both for a seiya defeat of
Barack Obama and of the Democrats in the
Senate but as important a takeover by
people who are actual limited government
small government cut the spending type
of candidates yeah I do think we have to
fire Barack Obama but the opportunity
for limited government guys is in the
Senate and I think there's a real fight
within the Republican caucus in the
Senate and we want to see if freedom
caucus be the majority of the new
majority so that Rand Paul and Mike Lee
they get to write the budget they get to
determine what the agenda is and I think
that's a serious opportunity in this
election all right well I want to thank
Matt kibbe the author most recently of
hostile takeover and the president of
freedomworks we're talking to reason TV
I think
much